ChessKid is fun!
Chess is great for the brain!
It's also fun to play!
And ChessKid makes it easy to have fun!
Whether your child is a total beginner or a prodigy
they can hop on and find a well matched opponent
from around the world at any time.
ChessKid is the safe, parent-approved
way for your child to play chess online.
ChessKid is educational!
To kids, it feels just like playing,
but chess is a great way to learn patience,
strategy, and critical thinking.
ChessKid features a comprehensive training program
that guides kids to level up on their way to mastery.
This curriculum is designed
to work with Common Core standards
and global educational guidelines.
There are more than 50,000 chess Puzzles
and a whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies, tactics, openings
and endgames, specifically for kids!
ChessKid is easy!
Whether you're a parent helping your child,
a coach managing dozens of kids,
or a school of hundreds!
ChessKid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress.
Each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many Lessons, Puzzles
and games were completed.
You can also organize kids into Clubs
and send them messages.
ChessKid is the online home of scholastic chess
for thousands of kids, parents, schools, and coaches.
Signing up is free and easy!
So, what are you waiting for?